i just wanted to
once michael i just thought of applejack
who passed away within the past year and
a half
just a great play
westbrook gets the three to drop
[Music]
15 for 22. jordan is two for eight
himself here's west referring to the
bucket with the finish they i like the
timeout 12 to the game to go with four
assists three rebounds
and bridges has it deflected by anthony
lakers on the break now
anthony finds welcome soaring in for the
finish i like that in a number of big
games throughout his career and as
delivered but i'm happy that i see that
he's playing with enthusiasm
westbrook again hop into the hoop
without a turnover in the corner yeah
the big thing now is you know you've
been able to get right here oh westbrook
what a move
the pitter-patter dribble
using the window earning the flex
because he never quit on himself again
till i like we say he keeps playing no
matter what the score is he plays hard
[Music]
he's showing now that he can get in the
paint
off the bench what a contribution
not in the game right now for charlotte
as westbrook buries the three
32
from russell westbrook he has 27 in the
second half humbly open up right
underneath the rim on the roll and then
smith once again doing the dance
westbrook again
russell westbrook
dazzling
in this second half
[Applause]
now i believe
coach the whistle is to make sure it's a
three